one reunited couple two murders and a
countless amount of questions welcome
back to Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
hello River babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and I'm
saying hallelujah because our TV prayers
have been answered with another episode
of Riverdale now this is your after show
for episode 212 chapter 25 the wicked
and the divine and before I preach to
you with my sermon of hisses and kisses
I'm going to confess the biggest
headlines of the week in the blue and
gold breakdown all right guys first stop
you're confusing the heck out of us
Archie now apparently the official Lodge
family internship is actually just
Archie running around town doing Hiram's
lowly errands now when Archie wasn't
dressing up as a snazzy server at pops
he was busy eavesdropping on Hiram's
shady associates at Veronica's
confirmation our chickens assured his
girl that he's very aware of her
father's misdeeds but he still chose to
tell Hiram the truth about Papa poutine
now the mobster was conveniently
murdered later that night but here's the
real kicker when it came time to offer
up the evidence to the FBI agent Archie
stayed silent now over on the south side
the pressure to find the decapitated
head of general Pickens put the
Serpent's in hot water with the cops
luckily the Cooper and Jones Detective
Agency decided to take on the case find
the head save the trailer park and the
twosome discovered that tall boy
actually did the beheading turns out
Hiram convinced tall boy to do his dirty
work for him so tall I also brought in
penny Peabody in hopes of dethroning the
Jones boys from the serpent throne nice
to try you big O accomplished nothing
lastly chick continues to be the worst
influence on Betty and a source of chaos
in the Cooper household not only was he
inviting strangers into the Cooper
household for job interviews but he also
showed Betty a 16 year old had a chat
with sex-crazed men online while being
half dressed herself I love talking to
you
as if that wasn't bad enough a
mysterious man arrived on the Cooper's
doorstep now when Betty arrived home
after a rendezvous with jug more on that
later she walked into a bloody surprise
all right guys now this episode was
jam-packed with murders but it also had
some pretty killer romance moments which
takes us right into our seven seconds in
heaven now last week I was worried that
Veronica was becoming a little too shady
but it seems that these commitment to
God has caused me to see the light I
just I don't want you to get hurt now
our raven-haired beauty spent most of
the episode worried about Archie being
dragged into her family drama and at her
confirmation celebration Ronnie was this
close to confessing her parents ruthless
plan but was stopped by the swoon worthy
declaration Veronica I love you and
there's nothing you could ever say that
would change that now all is well and
barchi land and if you've been praying
for bug-head to get back together well
then I've got good news for you while
I'm thrilled that Betty and Jughead have
happily reunited I'm not too pleased
with Betty keeping so many secrets which
leads us straight into this week's
hisses and kisses first up in hisses
yeah that first one is going straight to
Betty Cooper for a line to Jughead about
her clandestine kiss with Archie what's
going on girl now huggy told you the
whole uncomfortable truth about tawny
and Archie told Veronica about the
smooch but when you had to clear
opportunities to confess you chose to
keep your lips sealed don't act
surprised when this all blows up in your
face be another hiss is going straight
to the web-camera storyline now guys I
cannot stress how uncomfortable I was
during that brief yet disturbing scene
of 16 year old Betty sitting in a bra
and chatting with a stranger now let's
get real river babes mental health is a
serious issue and the way that it's
being sexualized is not okay now I
understand that Betty is struggling and
I really hope that we're gonna get more
answers on the subject but the way that
this dark storyline is being addressed
is really disappointing and I really
hope that young fans are seeing that
moving on is this too tall boy for
betraying the Serpent's but biggest
kisses have all go to the fact that
Cheryl wasn't the one who decapitated
the statue that would have been epic
pisses to Archie for confusing us with
his allegiance who are you really
working for red and a chick for
continuing his streak for being the
creepiest character on TV who comes out
of a job interview in a bathrobe and
drinking milk milk was a bad choice
and my final hiss is going to that
musical moment at the confirmation now
don't get me wrong guys I love Josie and
these voices but it just seemed a little
forced stop trying to make fetch happen
and what was even weirder was the fact
that had Josie not volunteered to do it
Veronica would have been singing solo as
she sauntered down the aisle but I'm not
Catholic so I don't know is that normal
tell me in the comments as for my kisses
I'm sending so many kisses to the happy
romance moments between barchi and
bug-head
now it's nice getting to see the gang
share some lighter moments in this crazy
dark town kisses to FP for standing by
his son and to meeting Veronica's
familia Hermosa especially her
scene-stealing Abuelita kisses to Hal
for leaving no one misses you dude and
kisses to Alice Cooper for still looking
fabulous even when she's mopping up a
murder scene alright guys now that does
it for my thoughts on this week's
blessed episode but right now hit the
comments and tell me your hisses and
kisses now what do you think of the dark
Betty storyline which character are you
the most worried about right now was
that a normal confirmation and what are
your thoughts on the latest barchi and
bug head developments tell me also
please give this video like chat with me
on Twitter about your all your latest
Riverdale theories and don't forget to
subscribe to e t--'s youtube page so you
never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets tune in next week to our preview
episode of episode 213 chapter 26 the
tell-tale heart to see if your comment
will be featured on the show and until
next time river babes bye bye
[Music]